open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five marquita is with
us in Atlanta Happy New Year marquita
how are you I'm good how are you happy
new year
how can I help okay so I am in 120
thousand six hundred sixty nine dollars
worth debt and we currently bring in
5000 $334 the math told me that the
longest taking me would be about five
years to do it but we're in our
apartment right now and we're learning
and this apartment has had mold and I
would like to move because our lease is
up in April and I'm trying to figure out
would that be a good decision because
over the past year I went for making
twenty four thousand two sixty one
thousand and salary good for you so
you're single no I'm married okay you
make sixty one thousand what does he
make 30 we have a $90,000 household
income you have $120,000 in debt what
kind of debt is it student loans 15 for
one car in 17 for the other about sixes
credit cards and then it's a medical
bills and how much is your rent is 904
okay and when you move what would be
your rent that's the thing I'm thinking
it would go up because most of the rent
around here where we live is a thousand
to about 1200 I really don't want to pay
more than 1200 . so well I don't really
want you paying more than 900 it's what
you're paying now it would be nice
well if I stay here
you died of a mold infection yeah I
don't think you're staying there but I
think we're going to say gosh we need to
move and we're going to move into
something that is 900 a month that's
clean okay all right and then you got to
start asking yourself what have we got
to do to get rid of a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars worth of debt you got
thirty five thirty thirty two thousand
dollars where the car loans right that's
a lot for somebody living in an
apartment okay a lot period but you know
you can work your way through this but
I'm probably selling one of those cars
if I'm you guys and get me a cheap car
paid for word beater while I get out of
debt and let's see if we can accelerate
this get out of debt process if you cut
up your credit cards yet did you or not
it doesn't matter get them out and cut
them up all right right now all right
you guys decide if you're going to live
in this apartment with two car payments
broke the rest of your life or not you
have to do something let's do some it's
radical kid something's gotta change
it's time to get fired I mean you're not
even making the playoffs much less
winning the Super Bowl it's time to stop
what I'm trying to get you to realize is
that when you get disgusted is when
you're gonna change but you you're using
credit cards you still got your credit
cards open you've got car payments
coming out your ears and you're not
winning you're going to have to get
radical to win and it's going to be it's
gonna require a dramatic mindset change
do you have children yes I have one
sentence how old is he he's five okay
when he goes to bed tonight as soon as
he goes to sleep I want you and your
husband to walk in there and look at
that sleeping child and make him a
promise that you're gonna change his
family tree by changing your dadgum
behaviors okay you can do this have you
two been the Financial Peace University
yet no if I give that to you will you go
both of you yes all right and then when
you're rich someday I want you to send
somebody else as your gift okay okay
because you're gonna be rich if you do
what I teach you to do but you're gonna
have to do it you have to get fired up
it's going you gotta get disgusted there
you go I don't care I'm getting out this
mess I'm sick and tired of making as
much money and being broke when you get
that thing going inside of you when you
get sick and tired of being sick and
tired that's one you're gonna change
kiddo that's when everything's gonna
happen and you go quit playing around
the edges of this trying to figure out a
way to cheat the system you can't cheat
the system it's freaking math it kicks
your butt until you kick its butt
somebody's gonna win this argument and
you got to win the argument so far math
has kicked your butt you got $120,000 in
debt and you live in a mold infested
apartment making $90,000 a year or the
five-year-old son get disgusted I'm
disgusted get disgusted you can do this
hold on we're gonna give you Financial
Peace University and you call me back if
you need some help as you're doing this